good morning belief nation today's
message is express yourself over to you
meryl streep is what you do an art is it
a craft is it a job I mean is it - or
mid falutin or a paycheck yeah I don't
know there when other people do it
sometimes when I watch other people do
it really well I think it's beyond an
art you know it's like me making music
but at its best
yeah that's best it's like flying you
know it's great that's great and that's
the part I wouldn't give up and that's
the part I won't give up even though I
love my children and being home and
doing what they need me to do I
certainly also need to
I don't think entrepreneurs truly
express themselves enough deeply
meaningfully express yourself enough
because you're spending too much time
thinking about what other people want
you to do right what your customers want
you to do what your friends want you to
do what your family wants you to do with
the people around you want you to do
your spending so much time worrying
about what other people want you to do
instead of thinking about what do I want
to do how do i express myself how do I
do the thing that makes me come alive
and makes me propel myself up and allows
me to provide insane value to the world
and the challenge is the hard part is
when you are living somebody else's plan
right when you live it up to somebody
else's expectations it's easier because
there is a plan right because they say I
want you to do this I want you to call
that person I want you to paint this
picture I want this to go on the website
I want you to follow this vision it's
easier because the plan has been laid
out when it's for yourself it becomes
uncertain because you don't have the
plan because you don't know how it's
gonna work out you don't know the steps
to take to get to where you want to go
you don't you don't know where you want
to go you have a pull towards a
direction you say huh I don't want to
try it that out and you don't know why
and they may be totally different than
what you've been doing your entire life
but you feel this pull in this direction
you have to go chase that you have to
express yourself and follow your
intuition even if that lasts for one day
even people and try it and say that was
terrible I'm never gonna do it again but
you have to follow that intuition you
have to be true to yourself and you have
to create a plan for yourself even
though it may not make any sense at the
moment because the docs never aligned
looking forward it's only looking back
you'll do all sorts of these different
things that seemingly have no connection
to each other but you fast forward to
the future you and you look back in your
life and say it all made total sense but
if you don't bet on yourself you don't
express yourself you don't give yourself
the opportunity to go out and chase
those things then it's never going to
make
in the future all it's going to make
sense is you live somebody else's
version of your life and set up your own
so don't be afraid to express yourself
so the question thing today is how are
you expressing yourself right now what
are you doing today to not live up to
somebody else's expectations but what
are you doing for yourself to let you
come out I'm really curious leave in the
comment below and I will join a
discussion thank you so much for
watching have an amazing day
continue to believe and I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
of espresso